Speaker 1: All right, let's hear from a few
more people. We take calls via The David
Pakman Show Discord, which you can find at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Let's go to David
Speaker 2: from New York.
Speaker 1: David from New York. You're on the air.
Speaker 7: Hi, David. Yes, we're
taking your question. Pleasure.
Just off of the bat, I wanted to ask your
opinion on Mayor de Blasio and his. Ending of
ending of his term, and I believe Eric Adams is
going to be the next mayor of New York City. I
want to ask you your opinions on it.
Speaker 1: I mean, I don't have any
particular hot take. You know, the
Speaker 2: the issue that exists
Speaker 1: perennially with the New
York City mayor is that as a mayorship,
it's a very powerful position. Being mayor of New
York carries with it prestige that being mayor of,
Speaker 2: you know, fill in the
Speaker 1: blank town and
Speaker 2: wherever state doesn't. And the other
Speaker 1: reality is that no matter what you do,
you will have a huge portion of
New York City residents furious
Speaker 2: with you, no matter what
Speaker 1: you do with extremely rare exception.
Giuliani after nine eleven, there were extenuating
circumstances. He had a high approval. OK,
so did George W. Bush, right? I mean, and then
that was squandered. But in New York City,
Speaker 2: you have, first of all,
Speaker 1: such political differences
from Brooklyn
Speaker 2: to
Staten Island. And then, of course, a
Speaker 1: mix in Manhattan and a mix in Queens
and Bronx is more left to fight. Politically, it's
dramatically different. You basically have the
Speaker 2: full political gamut
Speaker 1: in the city of New York. You have
Speaker 2: financially dramatically
Speaker 1: different circumstances.
And as a result
Speaker 2: of that, the policies
Speaker 1: of one mayor are never going to
satisfy people across class and economic lines.
It is a job where
Speaker 2: you, you are going
Speaker 1: to have a huge
portion of the city furious with
Speaker 2: you.
Speaker 1: And based on that,
you know, on Eric Adams specifically, I don't
really have any predictions or hot takes.
OK. Thank you for taking my call,
I mean, what are you expecting?
Speaker 7: I mean, from the
rhetoric that I've heard,
yeah, that we're looking at a Bloomberg white
version with Eric Eric Adams. And personally,
I don't have so much of a problem with that
regarding more of a. I would I would personally
say, an objective take on policy regarding
Speaker 2: companies
Speaker 7: in New York housing a weaning away
from a hard right stance and weaning further away
from an authoritarian stance that Bloomberg took
with things such as the soda ban and other very,
very unpopular policies that he was putting out
there for simply what looked like ratings kicks.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, I think I don't think
Eric Adams is going to be an authoritarian. I
don't think Eric Adams is going to be
Speaker 2: hard, right? He's also not
Speaker 1: the epitome of the progressive
left. I mean, my expectation is that it'll
be a relatively unremarkable mayorship.
Speaker 7: That or it could be a remarkably
good mayorship. Oh, maybe.
Sure, that's more optimistic.
Yeah, we could be. We could look at things
optimistically and noting all those things
that you just did. We could be looking at
something that could be starkly different
from anything that we have experienced.
Speaker 1: I mean, the thing is,
I think a lot of that is just going to ride on the
broader economy because New York City is such an
economically important hub of the United States
and global the global economy. A lot of what
determines whether people think Adams is
doing well or not is going to be the result of
economic factors that have nothing to do with him.
Speaker 7: Yeah, that or or on the on the other on
the other end of the spectrum negatively because
we are still looking at a a hemorrhaging city
that no amount of policy could possibly fix it.
And I mean, I didn't want to talk about anything
policy specific, but it now has
just come out that Bill de Blasio
Speaker 2: has just announced his most
Speaker 7: unpopular policy. And that's the
vaccine mandate for private businesses coming in.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And let's not even get into that
because I did do a segment on it. And so
I've covered that extensively. But yeah,
and I don't know if that's going to
be upheld, but we'll we'll see. But
listen, let let's see what happens. I'm curious,
as you are, to see what happens in New York City.
Speaker 7: Yeah, thank you, thank you again for
taking my question. It was great talking to you.
Speaker 1: Likewise, there's David from New York.
Speaker 2: Very much appreciate hearing from you.